[Música]
y hablamos ahora de economía y ya está
con nosotros en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches gracias por
estar con nosotros conversamos sobre una
norma que parece que va o busca proteger
a los viajeros que pidan reembolso por
vuelos cancelados mi lista sería
larguísima los llamé de vacaciones
muchos días y sobre todo después de la
pandemia bueno esta semana el
departamento de transporte de eeuu
propuso obligar a las aerolíneas a
reembolsar los pasajes y el horario de
vuelo se modifica significativamente o
si la compañía hace cambios importante
en su itinerario la propuesta endurecerá
la normativa existente y podrían exigir
a las aerolíneas y agentes de viajes
estadounidenses y extranjeros que
suministren reembolsos por cancelaciones
de viajes relacionados con la pandemia
en cambio de cupones o créditos de viaje
que no tengan fecha de vencimiento se
propone también que esta nueva norma
entre en vigor en un plazo bastante
corto de 90 días aproximadamente por
ahora se encuentra en consulta con el
público y la probable oposición de las
compañías aéreas conversamos antes con
él es piloto y editor de la revista
erwin magazine sobre los beneficios de
esta nueva norma y esto fue lo que
comentó si la norma beneficia en gran
parte a los pasajeros gracias a que en
las demoras que están sufriendo los
aviones hoy en eeuu que será un gran
gran parte por falta de tripulación
falta de personal de tierra y falta de
personal que hace el check-in en los
aeropuertos esas demoras que están
siendo de más de 34 horas de ahora en
adelante podrían ser
el motivo principal para que te
devuelvan el dinero para que tenga un
reembolso y para que los pasajeros
puedan olvidarse de él el problema de
tener que hacer una compra de boletos
nuevo en el futuro esa regla no existía
ahora si existe el aerolínea sas pues ya
fue la primera en dar un paso adelante y
decir vale está bien de cáncer un vuelo
tienes un voucher y este va a ser no va
a tener una fecha de expiración cosa que
no existía antes de esta discusión por
la ley nueva entonces yo estimo que las
otras aerolíneas van a ser lo mismo y
probablemente va a beneficiar en gran
parte a los pasajeros ya que si se ven
afectados por un problema operativo de
la aerolínea cada destacar operativo y
no por temas de clima este pues
obviamente va a ser un beneficio
importante para todos ellos bueno un
beneficio para los viajeros ya que vemos
que los servicios cada vez se cortan más
para los viajeros y toca pagar más
hablemos entonces de la agencia
estadounidense que ha criticado
precisamente a las aerolíneas en eeuu
por el aumento de los retrasos en los
vuelos a lo largo del 2022 jorge las
reglas de protección al consumidor se
flexibilizaron bastante durante la
administración del presidente de donald
trump
mientras los reclamos de los
consumidores presentadas ante el
departamento de transporte se
multiplicaron casi por 7 solamente en el
año 2020 con respecto al año anterior y
el 87 por ciento de esos reclamos fueron
específicamente sobre los reembolsos y
otra de las grandes quejas es que
hicieron las aerolíneas con las ayudas
públicas de 54 mil millones de dólares
que recibieron durante la pandemia
tomaron ventaja eso se lo preguntamos a
nuestro invitado si si lo tomaran
ventaja claramente el gobierno las ayudó
de manera importante les niego cantidad
de dinero realmente considerable para
que pudieran mantener a todo el personal
que tenían contratado y no despedirlos
no mandarlos a casa sin embargo las
aerolíneas lo que hicieron fue utilizar
esos fondos para poder mantener su
operatividad muy disminuida importante
recalcarlo durante la pandemia el 85% de
la flota de los aviones de las
aerolíneas los eeuu se vio forzada a ser
puesta en tierra en preservación y
durante ese tiempo todos esos aviones en
tierra obligaron también a la aerolínea
a ofrecerle paquetes de salida a sus
tripulantes más viejos los más longevos
los que más dinero ganaban entonces le
dijeron mira qué voy a ofrecer una
cierta cantidad de dinero y una cierta
cantidad de beneficios para tu retiro y
si lo tomas pues bienvenido y nosotros
entonces nos ahorramos tener en tierra y
de tener que pagar te todavía entonces
por ese motivo
todas estas demoras que se están viendo
hoy en día es porque no tienen
suficientes tripulantes los aviones que
estaban en tierra han regresado al aire
y no tienen con que operar los un grupo
que asesora el departamento de
transporte en ese país y que incluye a
los defensores de los consumidores
programó una reunión en línea para
discutir la norma el próximo 22 de
agosto esperemos que sea aprobada
seguramente es una muy buena noticia
para la mayoría de usuarios pero no para
las aerolíneas que han gastado mucho
dinero muchas gracias jorge por estas
noticias del mundo la economía punto
final a continuación el debate aquí en
directo américa